hola aunque la felicidad para usted es
bueno el primero en reaccionar al fallo
fue el propio novak djokovic en un
comunicado de prensa dijo que está
profundamente decepcionado por la
decisión de la corte pero que la carta y
que colaborará con las autoridades para
su salida del país dijo por último que
se siente incómodo con el hecho de que
en las últimas semanas la atención haya
girado en torno a él y no en torno al
torneo de gran slam también el primer
ministro de australia es con mayor
visión expidió un comunicado celebrando
la decisión de la corte y dijo que este
fallo ayuda a mantener las fronteras
fuertes y a los australianos a salvo y
la organización del abierto de tenis
dijo que acata el fallo también y ya
reemplazo en lugar de djokovic en el
torneo